there are some places you can't get to
it have the right gear at least it's not
these days if you only got a weekend
you're not going to walk 20 miles just
to see something but if you strap your
gear to a motorcycle it's almost as
nimble as your own feet suddenly you
find yourself taking in so much more
I picked the Cascade Mountains of
Washington State because they kind of
have everything the terrain was just
different every time you look down I
mean you get sore riding dirt physical
the bike is moving under your ways
you're not anticipating because the
ground is moving under the bike after a
while I realized just relax the bike is
made for this you have to let it react
to the ground in a way that you're not
equipped to it has the suspension it has
the balance and the center of gravity
that's made to soak up these bumps so I
had to let it out a little bit let the
bike go faster they're not comfortable
do
outdoor gear was some of the first year
from snow shoes that were made out of
strings and animal guts to skis made out
of roughly carved branches these are
things that allowed us to kind of adapt
our environment to ourselves it made us
more human the idea behind this trip was
to use gear not just to connect yourself
with somebody who is far away but to
connect yourself with a world that maybe
was a little too far away because we are
also surrounded by mountains rivers and
hillsides and sunsets and I think that
they lose sight of that little bit so
when you can find a piece of technology
that gets you away from technology but
you found something pretty amazing
hey